she's a health expert a best-selling
author given us a few tips this morning
to banish the bloat after all that
holiday over indulgence amy lee mercury
has a simple tea that you can make at
home and it's going to help you keep
feeling your best
okay so first of all we have
fennel seeds which you can get in
your spice department
very easy to use
and you really don't need a lot so you
use about half a teaspoon just a little
bit you can put this in a teapot you can
put this in a tea cup either way it's
fine all of your ingredients can go
either way so you put your fennel seeds
in and fun fact for bloating
if you chew a few fennel seeds that will
decrease bloating and when you're making
dishes that perhaps would cause bloating
things like cruciferous vegetables and
things like that if you use fennel as
one of the seasonings then you'll
decrease it as well then we have
fenugreek seeds
same thing mine are ground so you would
put your half teaspoons in those are
what we call a mucilaginous herb which
means they help everything move through
your digestive system easily gently and
without not digesting which is how we
get our bloating issue
all right so then you add powdered fresh
or sliced ginger about half teaspoon
helps digestion lime juice to taste
which jamie says is good for our liver
it helps move the bile and then a little
bit of stevia if you want it sweet
finally add that hot water let it steep
five to ten minutes or longer and amy
says you can drink this tea as much or
as often as you want we've got this
recipe up on our website so you don't
have to memorize it eight news now dot
com like those wellness shots it is and
so easy to make at home that's the good
thing i